le département vous présente terre de
trail
[Musique]
saint-pierre le stress le départ de la
diagonale un lieu où l'émotion se
cristallise et ça marcel c'est pourquoi
un bord de mer convivial propice à notre
rythme saint-marcel salut alexandre
répond le départ mais plutôt pour
découvrir un lieu historique a pas le
même rythme on coupe à annonay on prend
le temps la mélasse à dimanche tu vois
ouais mais regarde bien la savine manche
j'ai envie de courir dans l'océan
[Musique]
marcel thibault le conférencier mon
oncle s'appelait public le chercheur de
trésors et c'est vrai que dès mon plus
jeune âge j'ai été plongé dans la
marmite comme on dit je marque
communiquer cette passion pour
l'histoire de la réunion pour l'iss pour
la piraterie pour les contes et les
légendes de mon pays et c'est vrai que
lorsque je suis arrivé dans le sud il ya
plus de vingt ans maintenant je suis
tombé amoureux de son histoire et de ce
site que je n'ai pas quitté jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai ce que ce lieu est
plein d'énergie à cause de la course ou
parce que c'est ce lieu-là d'après toi à
cause de son histoire bien sûr histoire
de pirates de trésors cachés
l'histoire de son sellerie support
oblique à côté à la tombe de sites aran
[Musique]
alors le ce cimetière date du 19e siècle
à l'origine il se trouvait un peu plus
du côté du port de saint pierre à côté
en face de la capitale mais nous passe
dessus oui alors concours sur les
lancers cimetière en fin de compte oui
d'accord bons ballons vital au paquet
d'énergie tout ça
[Musique]
le grand raid c'est une course au bout
de soi même c'est une c'est une quête
une quête de sens de liberté de grands
espaces 5 km sur des chemins
inaccessible le soin au départ il ya des
milliers de personnes qui sont là pour
célébrer les coureurs et cela montre
bien que les saint-pierrois et les
réunionnais en général mais les sudistes
sont des gens passionnés qui aiment leur
territoire le département vous a
présenté terre de trail